let's go next to our caller from the
nine five four area code who's calling
today from 954 Joelle Joelle what's up
four lardo
yeah I'm Andrew Yanks supporter and I
was just I just wanted to get your
thoughts on the coming automation wave
and I know you don't you're not a big
fan of his UVI or universal basic income
but Bernie wants his answer for
automation would be a Federal jobs
guarantee I was wondering what would you
what would those two options for
automation what would you prefer and
it's like in the future you had to pick
one so I'm not against you bi I just
don't see you bi is the solution to
automation that I've been critical
before when Andrew yang said that ubi
any dollar you get from ubi you lose
from other benefits I want ubi to be
additive the idea is to raise people
standard of living not to just change
where they're getting money from so I'm
not against ubi in fact I've been
talking about ubi including with Andrew
yang on this program much longer than
almost any other show has I just don't
see ubi is the deal as the way to deal
with automation I think that there has
to be some kind of bridge solution there
are going to be jobs automated away it's
just a reality and what we have to think
about is which industries are likely to
be hardest hit what kind of retraining
can we do of people who are going to
lose jobs for moving towards industries
that are going to flourish or
potentially even grow as we continue to
move forward and for me it's it's not
about jobs guarantee versus using ubi
to pay people who lose jobs to
automation these are kind of all
disjointed things I think we need sort
of a much more holistic approach and ubi
for me is very interesting but not the
way to deal with automation alright
thank you very much I appreciate it all
right very good thank you so much for
the call we will go to a break and come
back with more right after this
sorry to everybody I was not able to
pick up on we always get more calls than
the number we can take but that's a good
sign that's a good problem to have quick
break back after this